[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH COGAN: Hi, there.
Josh here.
I'm a software engineer working
on Google Cloud's AutoML.
HEATHER CROSS: Hello, again,
and welcome back to episode two
in our series where we introduce
the exciting world of machine
learning and run through a quick
demo of our self-paced lab.
JOSH COGAN: Let's first recap.
If you'd like to see a
deep explanation of machine
learning, you can check out
Yufeng's AI adventures episode
here.
HEATHER CROSS: Machine learning,
artificial intelligence--
these are all major buzzwords
in today's cloud market.
But what's the difference?
JOSH COGAN: I like to think
of them as concentric circles
where you have AI as the broader
concept, ML as the algorithms
to make AI work, and
then deep learning
is a type of ML using
multilayer neural networks.
HEATHER CROSS: The core
activities in machine learning
include data gathering, model
building, training, evaluation,
and parameter tuning.
JOSH COGAN: Gathered data
is used to train the model
and evaluate its performance.
Algorithms iteratively
learn from data,
and then can make
predictions on new examples.
HEATHER CROSS: Tagged people
inside photos, viewing
and buying suggestions,
personalized search results--
machine learning is actually
behind a lot of what
we experience every day.
JOSH COGAN: ML's a great way to
jump-start any application that
already has many
examples of what
you'd like the algorithm to do.
Let's take a use
case from Google.
Do you use the OK Google
functionality on your phone?
HEATHER CROSS: Every day.
JOSH COGAN: Me too.
Well, to build it,
they had to gather
a bunch of different ways
people say, OK Google,
and use that to train
the ML algorithm.
The research team collects and
annotates many other spoken
phrases so that the ML
can learn to process
different interactions.
HEATHER CROSS: For those of
us without training data,
the Google APIs for vision,
natural language, translate,
and video intelligence
are already available,
and they're a great
place to get started.
Now the fun part--
Qwiklabs.
You can check out the link
to start the Qwiklab here.
JOSH COGAN: This lab provides
an introductory walkthrough
on training a TensorFlow model
both locally and on Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
Next, we'll learn how to deploy
to Google Cloud for prediction.
Keep in mind that this lab will
take about an hour to complete.
Here, we've copied
in some training data
from the census data set,
validated the model locally,
and run a single instance
trainer using Cloud ML Engine.
Now we're ready to deploy
the model to cloud.
On CMLE, your model will be able
to make predictions and scale
to serve many
concurrent requests.
Create a Cloud ML Engine model.
Select the exported
model to use.
Set an environment variable
for the output path.
Deploy version one
of the trained model.
This may take a few minutes.
Send a prediction request
to the deployed model.
The response includes
the predicted labels
of the example in the request.
Here, we have the
probabilities that the income
less than or equal to
50,000 or that the income is
greater than 50,000.
Well, that's all the
time we have for today.
We hope you enjoyed
this episode and would
love to hear more about how you
use or would use Google cloud
machine learning engine
at your business.
HEATHER CROSS: That's right.
And don't forget to check out
our on-air webinar series,
Qwiklabs, and our blogs.
All of the links are below.
JOSH COGAN: You
can also learn more
about machine learning
through our Google Cloud
on-demand courses on Coursera.
Thanks for watching,
and see you soon.
HEATHER CROSS: Seeya.
SPEAKER: Make sure to check
out last week's episode
about cloud identity access
management for your business.
And don't forget to subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]